[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la culture qui
malheureusement n'est pas présente dans
l'hémicycle monsieur le ministre je
m'adresse à vous car je connais votre
attachement à la défense du patrimoine
français défendre aider le patrimoine en
france est devenue une urgence le
patrimoine touche à ce que nous sommes
comme vous l'avez justement dit ce n'est
pas seulement ce que nous recevons c'est
aussi ce que nous transmettons le loto
du patrimoine est un vrai succès
populaire
preuve s'il en était besoin que les
français sont attachés à leur patrimoine
et lorsqu'ils jouent au loto c'est avec
la conviction profonde que les sommes
qu'ils dépensent vont au patrimoine et
ne remplissent pas le puissant fend de
bercy afin de ne pas tricher avec les
français le sénat a adopté le mois
dernier une disposition de bon sens
destiné à ce que la totalité des sommes
prélevées soit affecté à la sauvegarde
de notre patrimoine
malheureusement c'était sans compter sur
les députés lrm que stéphane bern en
colère a qualifié de technocrates
ce n'est pas moi qu'il dit c'est lui
l'assemblée nationale sous l'emprise de
bercy attendait a en effet annulé
l'exonération de taxe sur le loto du
patrimoine voté par le sénat
c'est méconnaître l'importance du
patrimoine facteur d'attractivité des
territoires de développement local et de
cohésion sociale qui attire je vous le
rappelle 90 millions de visiteurs chaque
année et impactent la vie de 5000
salariés de 500 mille salariés
comprenez vous monsieur le ministre la
colère de stéphane bern et êtes vous
favorable au retour de la taxe défendue
par le tout puissant je dirais le trop
puissant ministère d